what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin pumped to now
be talking about satisficing and
maximizing we have Alton son joining us
on the show hi Alton thanks for coming
on the program really excited for this
conversation those who don't know
Elton's background he is a systemic
satisficer and you can find this
Facebook link in the bio below Alton
what is satisficing it looks like this
just unintentionally where this is all
there is and there's nothing else her
period time hella kidding like time
budgets for anything you could everyone
to know for me than every thing that I
could ever want is a number of
conversations away and then I have like
dedicated time to have those
conversations in my life so this nice
thing it's like being happy with
whatever you have
I'll go with that
interesting
being happy with whatever we have
having some very specific conditions
that once met you're like stop looking
the cessation of seeking yeah or you can
satisfy some period of time to seek
things to to have an established for me
well it looks like an established upper
and lower bound of bandwidth their time
dedicated to that
how do we become happy satisfied with
what we have if we maybe have not enough
water I don't know I have far too much
privilege to actually deeply entertain
like what I can really look at it I mean
we do want me to answer theoretically I
mean yeah yeah because why I wouldn't
have access to my mental faculties if I
was actually that dehydrated yet so then
okay so then is that a balance between
satisficing and maximizing because if
you don't have water then you would
choose to go into maximizing your given
time that you have to go get water I
mean it wouldn't be a mental move at
that point my guess is I would be very
like reactive in like more embodied
animal state explicit in Thai - all
does this speak to modernity with our
lives and metropolis with so much access
within our grocery stores within our
conspicuous consumption habits does this
satisficing speak to being happy with
what you have and not needing to needing
to buy that next designer item that
sounds nice I mean yeah if that's how
you wanted it I know it's totally very
personal I imagine so your needs are
like to yourself - well candy largely
self defined from this frame but by
default yeah I have it that is you huge
amount of our generation has been very
well trained to believe that the thing
that's gonna really have us be satisfied
is outside of us it's just this one
product or one service away
and I have it that you can design your
out set of needs and like see how you
can regularly satisfy those and then
just come on counter
so do you with your own life identify
your individualized needs whereas mine
or someone else's that doesn't have
water is different and then right yeah
tell us about this originally I queried
like eight areas of my life common tools
we love life and I rate them out of ten
how satisfied do I feel and then I would
worry what would it take to be ten out
of ten over the next week what action so
I need to put on my calendar and service
of that which eight areas it's like
spiritual needs fitness romantic family
why I take so that was originally like
the beginning the year and then I moved
it to twelve and then now it's five so
it like it shifts over time exactly my
needs every quarter I update it so like
Fitness is no longer on there because I
have it that it's a current consistent
habit so I know I don't need to
regularly query something that is just
my current present be I'm noticing I'm
very feeling like informational right
now if you like that's connected okay
this is so cool so we can take our
categories of needs depending on the
level of privilege that we have based on
my I have a habit of drinking water
because I don't need to go to a well
with a jerrican for water well that
might be a you have it to you just walk
the two miles to do that every morning
you just take it for granted
yes yes but they're being Silicon Valley
when there's like everything's grabbing
your attention everything shiny yes yes
so there's a hierarchy of needs that
water when met at the convenience of a
faucet inside of a home it becomes one
that I don't even need to budget time
for or quantify as a basic need that
needs to be met anymore because as my
basic need has been met in that category
and yeah and I'm privileged enough to
where it will be likely the rest of my
life yeah hopefully yes yes and then you
had these other categories which it
becomes a little bit interesting
thinking about categories like
spirituality because that as a basic
need it feels like is a basic need but
it also is placed at the top of this
hierarchy that then once you have all of
these other things then you can pursue
self-actualization and transcendence but
some of the poorest people in the world
that aren't a part of the economic
machinery that are earning no $1.00
value per day are some of the most
spiritually actualized people easy to be
enlightened in a cave or in a smaller
impact group or yeah really depends what
what outcome you have it's harder to be
enlightened as a billionaire or a
president of a country or a CEO of a
company that type of stuff
easier to be enlightened in the cave
because it's like to a vacuum of sorts
where you you're not tested by your
family and company and staff and via the
selection effects of people who are in
high status or company positions are
sort of personality types are most
likely to be the type that is playing
the upping the numbers game and is
really good at leaning in the direction
they perceive progress endlessly that
occurs to me is it more maximizing
mindset sure yeah that makes it less
probable they would have access to that
state as easily oh so we can be so
ruminate ruminative in our maximization
frameworks of life that we don't take a
step into our satisficing frameworks I
mean most people I think a lot of us are
familiar with marginal returns curve and
the payouts we get sure smaller and
smaller over time is you keep leaning in
a direction of something that's paid out
for you in the past
sometimes when you're trading off again
like against family time before making
more dollars to show up in your bank yet
there's always a backlight but like you
know this to be conscious about where
that time and intention is guy that's
all this is a an intention another
gesture an invitation for for me yeah
yeah so you took a category like Fitness
which initially was something that you
would need to query about your life on a
on a frequent or frequent querying basis
until it became such a habit where it no
longer needed to be queried so like we
were talking about water as potentially
one of those that once there's daily
water then maybe you don't need to focus
two hours a day I'm going to that well
that type of stuff hmm but then you had
all these other categories like what
were you doing like how do you quantify
how do you query your own spiritual or
intimate with a relationship romantic
well-being how do you query those I mean
a common frame is progress is happiness
and if I ask myself do I feel 10 out of
10 in this domain in my life your brain
generally my brain well generate an
answer pretty easily
you start with do I feel 10 out of 10
for me in this domain yeah likewise I
don't for anything less
I guess look how this came out of me
sharing with previous I'm gonna to
partners how it my general experience of
the world is like ninety nine and a half
out of ten and it's pretty difficult to
prioritize because everything feels
great all the time like how do you do
that my ball but maybe I can put some
words to it make it more legible and
more people be in the state so I can is
there also so much subjectivity of one's
emotional state yeah totally because
you'll be all like hiding again you may
just want to be saying to yourself that
I am if I'm working a lot on this
project which I am and I'm not passing
as much time on maybe this intimate
romantic
score I may be then saying things like
my work score as I query is quite high
in my romantic score is quite low but I
may say that because I'm working so much
I'm consciously choosing to maybe
focusing my time on that therefore my
romantic score can also be high because
I know what I'm doing with my time but
if I feel deprived in that to like be
honest and about my own queries is
paramount I have to be honest and said
this helps me be in deeper inquiry
around those topics exactly that you're
doing the work right now so let's go
through the categories again that you
you have you had aid they shifted to
twelve and soon so yeah that's five five
yeah so what are what are the categories
fun like this for me follow the magnetic
fun no this is my intention guys see
everything as a Rorschach test there's a
what test Rorschach test
what's that again the Rorschach inkblot
test
look at it alot and you like project all
over the thing and then like you make up
some stories and that's basically our
entire lives
yes so it's basically our entire lives
we'll get to these other categories
after fun so sure okay other things are
like one wheel and circling online and
authentic relating games but yeah yeah
so are we so like I really don't want to
venture into consciousness is I have a
projective identification that's my
story
what my character suit and what Eldon's
the ego beliefs in the narrative self a
projection identification projective
identification like my parents or some
figure that I picked up pieces from like
modeled some behavior that they
projected on to me and I lived into
those beliefs they're listening actively
created me as a set of a sort of
creature that like values filial piety
or collectivist culture or guest culture
being able to infer your needs without
you having to explicitly state them and
these are all things like by no choice
it anyways I my identity is blended with
there's those projections to a large
extent my central nervous system is
wired around that whoa yeah okay we'll
give to these other categories in a
little bit just this is true this is too
rich here to leave so maybe it's related
to the second one being fate oh the
second one's fate yeah Oh interesting
contribution to community or impactor
yes what am I giving my life to you
Oh similar texture so what has you your
eyes light up her face
okay so
interesting fun and fate are these first
two that we're reviewing all right so
within I can do it and we can invite
other people do it you can do it I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's actually pretty
close to what the virtual assistant
taxes me about for two hours every
weekend this is this frame is to put
things in action yeah okay let's let's
uh let's unpack this since you brought
it up let's unpack this a little bit
we'll try and get to some of all their
weeds so you have a virtual assistant
that reviews your query into your it's a
facilitated conversation a facilitated
cars to show you but you self assess yes
for the first yes first minute we bring
to mind how does it feel Alton in the
domain of fun for you for this past week
okay I said with that for a minute like
review in my mind for playing those
memories what I must appreciated
interesting after that minute then I
give a reading and then I write for
another minute about why I was not
reading and the next few minutes is
putting anything on my calendar in
service of those so you write she he or
she asks you a question and then I wrote
a whole template for the conversation
you know yeah okay they ask you about
how are you feeling related to fun
regarding your fun you take some time
come up with a number I'll be like one
to ten I'll replay some of those
memories yeah you take your time we're
playing these memories not talking to
them about them we're talking to them
I'm not dying yet okay and then but I
assume someone could also do it where
they talk to the person about the
memories that was how it was originally
yes how was that why I do eventually so
first the minute is just silent sitting
with that generating them then I give a
number and then I
speak to it to why this show puts the
main keywords are like who I spoke with
and what stood out to me
this one depends for like what you
appreciate appreciates yeah I just see
I'll have that more available to me and
I will be more my neural Nets more
likely to reach out to these set of
people yes
yeah I feel very heady and procedural
eyes right now
um maybe I'd like to hey like maybe I'll
just put a template in the thing cuz
that uh it's probably higher fidelity
than me explaining it because maybe
someone's on the other and scrambling to
type things and I'm like you just let's
put a link in the bio to the template
however much you're willing to share but
I would also like to continue get
attacked right yeah yeah so I was mostly
just a stance towards the world was
satisficing that I've found it very
peace inducing a default stance of like
ecstatic peace
yeah but default stance of ecstatic
peace
that seems to me also like the drop on a
moment-to-moment basis being constantly
aware of the ocean
but feels resonant yeah
alright I know where's he said but yet
it just feels presidency
peaceful ecstatic yeah
so doing satisficing assists you with
the process of being in moment-to-moment
peaceful looks tasses okay in this world
like living in cities boxes yeah by
default a habit that our intuition will
like be actually wired around the
correct things but in this world of
super stimuli washes out are my ability
to sensitize my priorities myself to my
priorities so satisficing helps me that
was huge in this world of over
saturation with stimuli it makes it more
difficult for us to organize our
priorities yeah it me too
every person I talk to says that I
haven't met one person that doesn't say
that someone have to be in a cave so
that they don't have that happening to
them everyone's a part of the
exponential technology age people are
coming online everything that we need in
our filter bubble yes well everyone even
in parts of the world that don't have
smartphones yet are getting connected to
the Internet by the hundreds of
thousands so I don't really see how
people are not entering into the over
stimuli world
I think everyone's entering into the
over stimuli world there are maybe some
very few maybe indigenous subcultures
around the world that are not getting
smartphones that are staying in their
land but even then colonial efforts have
still somehow made it to like drag them
into the economic machinery somehow sure
but I want to be aware feels like we're
vilifying them in some way it might
think we're also wanting to tell the
universe with our values on this show as
much as as they are with their
industrial machine and we're like the
pattern that people like out of like The
Naturalist learn how to kill a chicken
so that's it's another yeah that's quite
extreme maybe more so the word balance
comes up a lot and you see indigeneity
you see modernity and you see a balance
that can harmonize to maximizing
prosperity satisficing prosperity that's
what it feels like has been a main ethos
of the show and our conversations on it
especially in the last couple months is
finding that exact balance yeah well you
can engineer it yeah we're in the
process of doing that architecting and
you have this format with satisficing
with the virtual assistant every yeah
two hours every week four hours every
week two hours for that framework and
two hours later for like setting those
into action and like being on the court
or like in my life reaching out to
people following up with things the
intention is between 80 and 95 percent
calendar integrity so yeah follow
through with everything yeah I'm there
and it's basically a practice in the
source of all confidence I have found is
in regularly seeing my intentions cohere
into accomplishments and calendar
integrity and having confidence that
anything I thought my calendar will
arrive or arise in my life
because I'm that type of person is like
deeply satisficing and
it's inducing me yeah and that's what
the only two irises I like the focus on
following up on your self-assessment
with a virtual assistant you're
following up so those other two hours
are the follow-up to see how you are
performing with increasing your fun or
fate or spirituality or romantic or
whichever one of these categories up
from six to eight like you wanted to do
or you want always ten you said there's
a necessary with eight categories I went
to twelve categories identified but I
meant the rate ranking itself like if
you're at six out of ten and romantic
you would never shoot for eight you
would only shoot for ten oh yeah yeah
tolerating anything yeah yeah kind of
life and I said why would I ever do that
yeah okay suit but I I am if I'm doing
it unconsciously or if I don't take this
on as a practice in my life if I'm
speaking to like five year ago me
knowing about it now I am unconsciously
condemning myself to that type of life
yeah it's a probable almost certain
future yeah yeah so we we have a it's
important for us to pursue a 10 out of
10 across all of these need categories
for me yeah that's that's the world I
would like to see and that framing yeah
it's generated from world peace through
inner peace yes why would someone need
to logis eyes their life to this degree
yeah I mean I'm just high participant
izing and grew up in Silicon Valley
I mean it's AK
I'm a outgrowth of the set of neuroses
that found my subjective experience I
imagine that the types of other people
who identify with ADHD or just being
soaked up in like my nail
they're just more powerful systems that
will like hijack your nervous system
otherwise and I have it that you can
choose to be a myself author in this
case oh now we're at the key point yeah
I see interesting the true-self
authoring rather than the hijacking yeah
okay
I see how logis sizing via this
resolution of querying these need
categories is deeply helpful for self
authoring yet also is
mmm maybe overly quantified selfie at
the same time yeah I mean it's all
relative to I mean people who journal
once a month could be considered overly
quantified self for people who general
six times a day could be considered over
quite a myself for this pattern I always
know about it or those little biometric
devices I capture biometrics they're
like watching the heart rate variability
every second but this and I go
maximising I'd said if we cram more
features and it will sell them more than
things do do what serves you right do it
works and some people's lives my life
that at some point felt occurred to me
is not very workable and so committing
to this counter integrity and committing
to this frame with these assistants has
made my life occur to myself is much
more workable and I have fluency with
whatever intentions and I would like to
cohere his accomplishments that's like a
something I could never otherwise
personally like experience as
intentionally pirate to the system in my
life yeah
have you idea how much it bill I've
shared it with several other fund and
founder friends and then they they found
it very good liking I did they took to
it yeah yeah I'm I'm vibing with
satisficing my life I am very passionate
about self authoring rather than
hijacking and that's actually something
on the show that we talk about quite a
lot is know thyself and self author
thyself otherwise there's many of other
institutions that are wanting to
indoctrinate your spirit nervous system
into their self authoring okay there's
nowhere else to be for me because I got
the time budgeted here and I'm here and
everything else is just not in my
existence right now and I can't afford
to be fully present here right now yes
yes that's right
you can tell by the look when there's
that full presence into here
oh maybe maybe you can I can't tell that
yeah but yeah my internal experience of
myself
yes yeah my internal is well sounds what
are the other categories fun fate
romantic physical is that family family
feelings and finances and I wanted to
book in like the alternative world is
where I can't afford to be fully present
with you you probably know when a
texture is like to be with somebody
who's like oh like what time is it in
like okay I'm here but I'm like halfway
out of the conversation because I'm like
following up with this text messages on
a guy like do these all those others
after things and like I like this thing
it's a really important later today and
by the way these other thing happen and
I oh my god it just I'm so pulled in so
many directions and there's a certain
texture yes that being with that person
has that's like mmm is that the life I
want to have an impact with thousands of
people
I'm interact with in a thousands people
they're gonna react with that when I
want to put in the world I could you
know I got we have systems like I'm
trusting you to facilitate the thing and
my phone was at some point and I'll be
like I'll do another thing and then I'll
be fully with that yes that was that
they wanted to share the contrast to
share what I like how you use the word
texture the texture of here now present
is wildly different than the texture of
being being being buffoon I gotta run I
gotta run cat it missed my bus yeah and
that's fine too like I have compassion
for those states in like my version of
me like five years ago or so and
it was a it makes this state that much
richer and more enjoyable what I try
that character Sudan for a little bit
where I'm being the presence of someone
else who maybe has only ever known that
character suit yeah do you feel like
you've self authored your life more
towards the peaceful of status character
suit sure I mean but if you query me at
any time if acquired me five years ago I
would think I would profess the same
thing to imagine me like a totally
different person like Oh what was I
thinking doing that it's a displaced if
you can so like you know well you know
me like I'm gonna have a lot of
compassion for that past version of
their doesn't it feel like we look back
at seven years ago Alton and Alan and
not only have compassion but also that
we have we have love for the
evolutionary trajectory we have you
think that peace yeah the peep of
peaceful next Asus seven years ago was
you'd say present for you at that time
it's really hard to quantify these
things but it seems like it totally I
guess wow this is so hard to go about in
logic land probably today I could I
would probably like probably try to
corner it if you were querying me in
that way I would probably use logic as
violence to try to corner some argument
into how I was already that
and I would do some spiritual bypassing
or something and believe I was in that
state maybe or for me I would have maybe
said what was coming up right away was
no I wasn't in right now maybe it feels
like I am more of the time in the
peaceful status so maybe 7 years from
now I would be saying that I was more
I'll be happy once I get to you later
the grass is greener oh yeah I'll be
happy once I peaceful ecstatic every
moment but it seemed to give it to
yourself now this is the question we
were asking at the beginning to around
the these quote-unquote basic needs
being met there's still many subcultures
around our planet that have deep amounts
of interconnectedness with each other
and their environment and they have a
close tie with the hydrological cycle to
get them the water a close tied with the
different areas of land that they go and
different get food from different
mindsets and different environments that
have them more sensitized to their
intuition going though environment yes
definitely but they have peaceful extent
not always but sometimes there can be
found a moment-to-moment peaceful at
status in that symbiotic process whereas
the metropolis is I feel have more of
the Bing Bing Bing bong I'm late blah
blah then symbiosis with we don't even
see the stars here we don't exchange a
sheet of paper for the Apple yeah if I'm
a big CEO of a company that's totally a
my incentive to put people into
situations where they are I squeeze all
the life out of them as my employees to
top my bottom line so you can buy my
fourth out of her 17th for Ari
for that - yeah and we'll keep doing it
because we're humans and that's okay we
can spiritually enlighten the whole
civilization if they're open to hearing
them but it's more intoxicating like
when you're intoxicated you can't make a
sober decision around the thing like if
you're if you've gotten everything you
thought you could want I can till we hit
rock bottom they're not really gonna
till they find themselves like in a
state of desperation that you probably
won't have the ears to hear or if we
have the biometric measurement of a
state of interconnectedness we can
measure a corrupt politician versus the
Dalai Lama and show that that is not
enlightened and that there's a
neurofeedback system that creates
enlightenment for that person in the
position that they're in so it may be
yes a rock-bottom scenario where they
realize that the seventeenth car for the
fourth daughter isn't happiness but
there may also be a science and
spirituality marry to be able to show
biometric states of unconditional love
and interconnectedness that then can
awaken us further to achieving those
states towards enlightenment faster
around these buying these trains because
it does eek of maximizing culture oh
yeah more faster more enlightenment
now more enlightenment ninety-one
maximize enlightenment yeah so I guess
today boy it feels like the goal is to
evolve consciousness
towards a more enlightened state yeah
and in you were know people I don't know
if I have that explicitly in I - like a
goal internally or the ownership is like
to be a clearing for miracles to arise
and some of the frames like satisficing
and maximizing being aware of that
distinction leads to more what occurs
miracles in my life like things I had no
previous reference class for that occurs
like deeply generative for ecstatically
peaceful
I yeah I have it that my life's more
easeful and fun fun yeah more people
have access to this language or this way
of being sure everyone has their own
self-sealing beliefs right what you just
said though is so very important that we
have a happier healthier more conducive
social fabric when more people have
access to the tools of enlightenment
that's been my experience so far but
tomorrow I could have a difference for
sure maybe another thing that can be
referenced as we talk here is you had
other categories that many of us feel
like we want to achieve a 10 in that we
may only be a six in so you know let's
talk about there were other ones you
listed there family finance family
feelings if I have feelings and finance
yeah
let's talk about those and fate and
maybe just sharing the downstream
leverage I encourage people to write
down or just set it to minute timer and
generate all the whole sequence of the
people were they interested yeah but
it's important that they're personally
owned and that they generate these areas
of life that are important to them
that it's like a length that it feels
good to end like yeah something that
they own and stepping themselves so
template izing my chosen ones after
doing several iterations over the past
three fourths of a year is gonna give
you a very different result
so family yeah
it occurs to me that family is a much
more difficult frame for a lot of
friends
hyper individualist culturing often
easier I'll be like yeah please don't
getting in the okay boomer meme and all
that stuff
Wow and I have it that if we don't feel
complete with family your parents and
I'm like accepting and generous and
compassionate in those ways then you set
yourself up to having that play out also
with your kids yeah with your so yeah
yep
how do we skillfully navigate that well
asking this question me and then
enrolling and requesting my family to
like play this game with me playing the
game at 4:10 a to 10 family laughing and
what did you do when you asked your
family to play ten attend family life
did you ask them what a 10 out of 10
family life would look like exactly and
they don't share vision like traveling
to friends together like having these
dinners together and I majored with her
also like what what I'd like to see you
two that helps like pave the way and
then like I want to be able to feel
great about traveling with them like
don't currently feel I guess to that but
I would like to
and so facilitator every week for two
hours facilitates like the conversations
that I would otherwise totally avoid or
just it feels really spiky or
uncomfortable around you just go right
for the thing and then when I regularly
see myself bring up topics that are like
really uncomfortable or like otherwise
people would avoid and then at the end I
feel or I connected with her and like
we're hugging each other and then she
put like making food in the kitchen
together I would otherwise never see
that like let's deeply meaning for me so
there's a process of asking your family
members for what they would have as
their 10 out of 10 family life vision
after I've enrolled them in sharing with
them what I not to create and if they
would like to participate in that they
would like yeah yeah participate in this
game then they hope hopefully if they do
choose so to say yes then then you you
gain awareness of what their 10 out of
10 variables are what they would like in
that vision right that can be like I'm a
yes to like the traveling thing but not
a yes to like traveling with you and
these ways are like yes to traveling
with you but I would need and I would
need a facilitator and I would
wanna you you reference this earlier -
so it's skillful to have a facilitator
when we need it for me and Wendy my
experience sure okay I mean I needed of
courses I am struggling to get to a ten
out of ten family a facilitator how do
we identify a trusted facilitator and
then how do we approach that
conversation with a facilitator our
parent has to be open to that or our
family member has to be open to that
which is in itself may be a challenge
sometimes yeah definitely like I mean it
was by a half year lifetime product
about half of your process of now maybe
well here regularly expressing that but
it was up to me and to offer something
that's attractive enough for her to want
to see it but she's also I grant center
stage where they like you know hey we
did our thing and now we want to enjoy
life and if talking with you occurs is
like stressful or I don't want to talk
about something that you want to talk
about something that's it's not strongly
to their incentive but can I speak to
like what love I see possible and a
family that I like painted vision and
their mind that occurs to me is like if
my parents are people that I can go to
when I like need a shoulder to cry on
and share that was something I want to
create then that leaves them a different
space and I'm just I'm requesting if
they would like to play this game with
me but I'm not attached to that we said
and who's like impact on who I get to be
around them
say no but being a gentle consistent
request he's like for me like true
commitment that's really what I'm
wanting to create a gentle consistent
request yeah that's well said so
so a gentle consistent request for my
family to want to have a 10 out of 10
family happiness satisficing and this is
the speaks really heavily to your focus
on this type of quantification assisting
with self authoring because if we don't
frequent our query towards family being
10 out of 10 and then it slides down as
my experience or or it may slide if you
are spiritually enlightened it may slide
up slowly over time we've had many
guests on the program talking about how
their path of spiritual awakening makes
it so that when they engage with their
family members that they themselves kind
of Oracle II butterfly effect out
awakening States to their family members
or their friends etc but that's still
not again gently consistently asking for
may we write down what a 10 out of 10
family vision would be I mean sharing it
in conversation or sharing it in
conversation and that be so but then you
also indicated that your family member
may say something like I would like to
do this but then you may say well maybe
yes to that but no to that
for me so that's why it's also good to
write because then it helps so yeah this
is kind of the also the idea of deals
and contracts the social contract
between people where if we agree that a
10 out of 10 family life looks like when
we make this contract around a specific
thing that we uphold that agreement
towards that specific thing or we or if
you don't want to anymore you approached
me and talked to me about that
specifically interesting basically in a
nutshell also it's creating hyper
transparency in your life and an hyper
awareness about all of these needs and
also of the closest people to you as
well yeah yeah I mean hearing that maybe
some of this may be acquired from a
previously did these relationship
agreements what's this in my social
contract for for some set period of time
I'm like fooling and until whatever the
period was either like a month or a
quarter and then a year they just I'm
fooling and like there's no need to know
code switching costs because I'm just
I'm here and upper and lower bounds
established for like what that looks
like for quality time and just mean
really explicit about people's neither
man
this also reminds me of even almost now
approaching two years ago we've had
guests on the show that have been
talking about how they have very unique
relationships with their family members
or their partners and their romantic
relationships with their friends where
they'll do things like chunk out a month
or three months and then they'll have
very specific things that they've tried
to codify about their interdependence on
one another and it's dynamic if certain
things aren't working you may switch
them over time but then after a month or
those three months you kind of look at
them again right where where your needs
being met with this with your own self
or with your romantic partner or with
your family with your friends yeah
recorder we would ask like the whole set
of questions some of those are exactly
alike is there anything that you're
sacrificing to be in this relationship
together and is there anything that you
would like to shift about that if that
is the case is there anything that's in
the space between you that you would
like to address that you haven't had an
opportunity for if you think about the
last corner
you know
I'm feeling really good I'm feeling
really awake
you can only see what you like it's so
interesting because Silicon Valley and
the quantification culture can both get
a good rep because if your heart rate
and heart rate variability and your
microbiome and regions that are being
mapped maybe there's a way to predict a
pathology before it gets there and you
can pass that additional ten years with
your family because you actually cared
about quantifying your biometrics Thanks
then there is also this inundation with
data and noise that were experiencing
that's causing these textured states of
like and then there's this textured
state of peaceful X tasses that is
described by many as feelings of the
drop merging with the ocean feelings of
Eagle loss or ego death feelings of deep
interconnectedness around conditional
love that if you add quantification to
that and start saying okay virtual
assistant you have a script where you're
asking me about how I felt this week
regarding my metric of unconditional
love regarding my metric of states of
deep interconnectedness so I have one
here's one I like you leaned everything
as God or as the one or source or
whatever people want to call it and I
frequently look in the morning when I'm
waking up do I feel everything as God in
their day do I feel everything as God at
night do I feel everything's gone and I
review my day how was my day in terms of
feeling everything as God look at this
maybe then this does come with even more
self authoring towards peaceful it
status if I also bring on a virtual
assistant which again this is all going
to be templated in the bio for you guys
that if I query my own peaceful status
with the assistance of a virtual
assistant in the process that I may be
able to achieve and not like a
maximization sort of way but rather a I
will I think peaceful status makes me
feel better in my moment-to-moment life
so I think that would be great for
myself because it really is
dichotomizing the inundation with data
and tasks and stuff with also the
picking up of some data and some tasks
which are just more oriented towards
peaceful X tasses and less oriented
towards and more oriented towards your
needs and what you want in life I have
its integration yeah habits of I have it
that that's a form of integration a form
of integration both you're able to meet
your needs like monetarily or what
everything else there may be
through this like unifying system of
having it all in the calendar where at
all points there's just only one place I
can be and my calendar is telling me I
have to hold all that my mind there's no
cognitive load like my Mac Zuckerberg
where all the people don't have to like
Barack Obama don't have to lose
cognitive load on choosing what to wear
that day it's just so my calendar it's
writing on the thing live out of your
counter and then it's great you don't
have to constantly be querying yourself
am i seeing this and my witnessing this
is god is syste this becomes a default
way of being for me that's not helpful I
will get back to where I want to go in a
little bit but I want to address this
point you just brought up which is is it
then that having a analysis of my
microbiome where a nutritional AI coach
is then shipping a drone with my food
for that meal to me so that I am NOT
choosing what I eat when I eat is that
what if you have that sustainably that's
available for you in your life and the
payout is worth it
relative to God I mean sure it might but
I don't I don't we gave these examples
of my clothes being picked for me my
schedule all being in the calendar so
I'm not there's no cognitive load in
that so is that the same thing if you
authored for food okay so if we've
altered that you know for me if I have
relative confidence that like losing
that wouldn't be catastrophic
so there's a world where I do that for
so long that it atrophies
my ability to to generate that
independently and there's some
probabilistic future where like boy
reason Google Calendar doesn't exist
anymore but there's probably like other
calendars that will satisfies the same
result but for like this AI drone
sensitizing myself to like what I'm
actually hungry for and then never
having to prepare food there's a world
where no no I'm still pretty confident
but teammates have pretty good intuition
they're in service of reducing cognitive
load for me yeah this is quite an
interesting subject given the digital
super intelligence revolution that were
and turning into because maybe there is
some of that intuition around something
to where or intuition around something
to do that day or intuition around with
food to get or intuition where to go
with your family on that vacation around
that critical path of conversation that
maybe an AI coach no matter how many
permutations has run may somehow not be
able to get that could be interesting
well they're also predictably irrational
just exactly so then could it be then
that there is not so much room for these
decisions around what we wear what we
eat what we do in the day that it's just
better to have the digital super
intelligence acting that out for us I
mean that's what I have my calendar be
for me yeah and my virtual assistant and
the calendar coupled together is
effectively those super intelligence
that that past version of me during that
two-hour window smart more intelligent
than the me that's sitting like deciding
do I want to watch TV or do on a play
video game right that's probably not try
not but like in those moments I'm like
oh yeah that's definitely the good idea
but like nope so it's super intelligence
because like mediated through that
virtual assistant and through my
calendar I'm like oh this is the thing
I'm doing even if I want to do something
else that's like the Sun there is the 80
to 95 percent calendar integrity so if
it's too high than I have it that I'm
shooting it too low
and it's low lower than 80 percent
integrity then it's fun work
okay the low still some flexibility let
me give let me get a example from you of
calendar integrity like you said eighty
to ninety five percent so there may be
scenarios where it feels too
constricting give us scenarios of this
if I'm just no longer a super heck yes
to whatever the texture so like to
running I knew got an adventure and I
think I was really just feeling or
craving just more quality time with my
friends in their house and they can
choose not to go to the underground
adventure but it has a similar texture
or shape a pattern of like Chloe time
with friends University
I guess it's a most common case
sometimes if I have slowed down there to
write something it was a common
procrastination point if I move it back
three times then I have to admit to
myself it's not important enough yeah
these are all downstream though I feel
like I could go into all the if things
but I really I do some of those with
it's great because you can click and
drag the the events in the calendar over
so if you click and drag it over and
then you finish it that's great but if
you don't after three clicks and drags
of it over then it's not important
enough they have to admit that to myself
right it'll be revealed during the oh
because your assistants also viewing
your calendar yes he has access to it so
if things are not executed and they've
been clicked and dragged over or you
cancelled them there will be clear
transparency I'm considering having it
fully public there's also really helpful
for coordinating with friends because
I'm generally very open to having other
friends join yeah that's quite
interesting also this complete
transparency life where all of your
biometrics all of your demographics your
psycho metrics all of your calendar all
of your messages all of it is completely
open like a book I would personally like
that world but I recognized there's a
lot of ethical implications and other
people are not nearly as open to that as
I am I've also proposed that style of
world and I've gotten pushed back
specifically regarding fear
fear of hate crimes this type of stuff
that's was the big one and this is why I
think going towards a spiritually
enlightened civilization makes it so
that there is no hate that then makes it
so that the complete openness of the
biometrics and the calendar and the
messages etc can be perfectly fine but I
like my frame on spiritual enlightenment
would include hate and would welcome
hate how so how so happy that it
welcomes the full spectrum of
possibilities world yeah probabilistic
Lee where it is basically not existing
or people don't take hateful acts out
into the world but that it can still be
present in someone's mind and that to be
welcome to and for okay so hate can be
welcomed in the mind as long as it's not
acted upon in the world
no I mean I don't know if I'm saying
that yeah this is this is a very also
challenging one because we stronger that
yeah I don't think someone's in light
unless they can welcome fully the whole
spectrum of emotions
yeah but welcoming the full spectrum of
emotions is I think still a world
without hate in the sense that if hate
arises it can be welcomed and it can be
if you want to immediately moved on from
to love if they choose to be in a
hateful state for the rest of life then
that's their choice as well
yeah but they're hateful stay for the
rest of their life we'll have a
butterfly effect on the rest of our
world and enlightened world when to have
a these hateful butterfly effects
cascading out in the world I know it's
very abstract and and far but very
present for you Emily sounds like a lack
of acceptance to me
it is I like it as well I would like to
understand how to architect that world
but I also realized that starting right
now
yeah yeah I don't I don't I don't know
that I guess that doesn't that doesn't
resonate with me so much I don't know
why that welcoming anger and hate into
my essence doesn't resonate with me I
want to radiate your essence but to love
me I don't see these things are strange
these words are strange because I feel
like words I feel like the enlightened
civilization would be around being
transcending hate I hear spiritually
bypassing hate I don't know if that's
the same those aren't the same to me
spiritually bypassing hate is it occurs
to me as like a core part of the human
experience and that referred to - like
transcending that core part of the human
experience
yes let's see the core okay so we have
some emotions as can I share this with
the honest rage and anger and this is a
Plex we love emotions I can unless if I
can feel the full and welcome to full
spectrum of emotions that are on that
for any given state I don't feel like
I'm fully feeling and I fully experience
things at 11 p.m. it opens up quantified
self now they're automated script thing
that I load in the morning at 9:00 a.m.
it opens with my journal and then
attended oh interesting to get you to do
the yeah it doesn't matter like what I'm
doing it's gonna be okay I'm opening
this up in 10 seconds your journaling
right now yeah yeah okay so ecstasy
vigilance rage loathing grief amazement
terror admiration yeah yeah and so I
feel I get to feel that well I usually
use this ring which is more okay the
next ring up is joy anticipation anger
disgust sadness surprise fear and trust
so I get different those that aren't
getting this on video for those that are
only getting it on audio that's what
it's a yeah it split check of PLU TCH I
K flight chicks we live in motion how do
we spell it again PLU t CH AI K PLU TCH
i ka plot chick so we love emotions now
albeit you can go to I don't understand
why you love why is love in this top
right corner so far away from the center
it's just it's as gradients and in terms
of intensity so the closer towards the
center the more intensities yeah but why
is love in that corner so far away from
the intensity of the center
I think it happens to be between joy and
trust in this way I'm very skeptical of
things like this albeit Jer quite
interesting I mean all models are false
some are useful all right you may find
it you may find it useful
I personally don't try and subscribe to
rage and angered for me to get some sort
of like a feeling of all feelings
it sounds like anger does it that's why
rejection like could easily exchange
that word rage with rape and say that oh
[ __ ] we should all experience rape so
that we have experienced all different
types of emotions to welcome the set of
feelings or textures that arrive with
that otherwise if you suppress it you
will often like be a defect of it or
it'll fester and then blow up in and
you'll find yourself in a state I think
that people can awaken to how rape is
[ __ ] and then they themselves can
educate their children as their children
are born into the world that rape is
[ __ ] and that I'll answer that that's
action I think it's easier talking about
emotions for me okay yeah and I think
that a motion that arises when one's in
a process of violence or pillaging or
any of those other things has to do with
rage and anger you can also have to do
with gluttony or corruption or jealousy
or greed the tumor could be pressing
against someone's amygdala and they
could go out and kill someone right so
there's so many components and variables
that go to this and this model may be
helpful in some ways but what is love
like some random thing in the top right
corner meanwhile all these in the center
are you know there's just like I my the
world that I care about architecting is
love period and then if you want to go
through this catalog of emotions that
even some of them are in the categories
of rage and anger then simulate that
experience for yourself in this catalog
of conscious experience that you can go
into but when you take rage and anger
and try and bring them out into the real
world you kill someone or dies in it no
you said you said you don't bring it out
into the physical order yes yes so even
if you like navigate your states of
anger or rage in your own catalogue of
experience and consciousness I mean that
in many ways or you're a defective I
don't know I don't know I don't know
this is a very interesting subject as
well just there's something deep about
it that feels like when I go to push
button myself into anger or rage that I
don't feel love at that same time and
that may be problematic in ways for
butterfly affecting out even though you
say it doesn't act in the world it may
still act in the world
nicely if you don't allow yourself a
healthy space to experience that
internally and be with that fully even
at the temporary cost of love maybe then
we'll pass tearing that will take effect
three I mean I have it that a large part
of the last running two-minute window I
would my story of my projection you were
at effect of anger that's my judgment
that's that would occur to me is like a
less high alien state not something I
would want personally
there's nothing she's like it's just
things just are the argument then would
be that something like an emotion wheel
would need to be explored throughout
life otherwise then if hate or rage or
anger or violence are never explored
then they would erupt like a volcano
sometime down the line yes I don't know
if I agree with that
as if so it occurs to me this is a very
valuable tool to navigate those
hierarchies
being able to have self-sufficiency to
recruit those resources systems that
generate those resources personally
totally yeah I love I'm all ears for new
or alternative systems totally this is
just what happens to work for me so far
right I probably would rationalize
whatever sis I was using ten years ago
you asked me then
this has been an interesting couple
minute put into this area super cool to
unpack with you that specific one yeah
looking forward to what the
architectures are so looking forward to
that
okay I wanted to ask you about the other
ones that we didn't get to another one
is finance one that so many of us are
would like additional abundance in so
what does a it looked like when I self
author myself towards ten out of ten and
have a virtual system that's constantly
checking my process towards that
constantly checking is once a week for
two hours but yeah well yeah or maybe
ties to me twice we don't gotta go but
that's still like routine checking sure
it's a routine ok so what does that look
like for Finance for me this is a fairly
downstream thing that I'm hesitant
because a lot of people try to Tempah
ties like what did this successful
person eat for breakfast because there
now there is he--oh so therefore I made
this breakfast table you see I mean like
so I mean just regularly asking myself
what would take to be 10 into 10 into my
finances I mean the first several times
were like just having confidence in my
budget well your time is like two having
confidence in the next you remember like
a couple week period of my life and a
couple months and that's cool years and
then this last weekend we did it for the
scale of decades and to just know that
work here's the plan this is what I'm on
track for and to have this overall sense
of like my comparative advantage right
now maybe these these set of things
these are things that could be attuned
to later on my life these things will be
easier for me so I
like min/max my skill points in these
domains well this upcoming week is just
for a new place I'm moving into and yeah
it's a it's a magic community house
magic community house Eco magic gorg
Oh eco magic org nice nice so it's a
like coal living with other like-minded
hmm like why don't you sing like minded
but also not in some ways enough to have
him a medically relax yeah and nothing
to have that area life descriptor
easement yeah but people don't care
about this about I like that they were
they were fairly distinct by super
workable and they've been on for 40
years as a community house and I'm Mary
thanks anyways think rebel says and so
with the deposit not bad yes yes so to
be with their systems and like I'll
spent a lot of time with them over the
next period didn't like what was the
concrete outcome
[Music]
I can take my counter right I mean
what's the well this kind of leads us
into the point about intentional living
spaces mm-hmm
is this an intentional living space yes
very much so
okay there's a pretty extensive anything
okay so I didn't watch much videos and I
care about you let's regain what do you
see in these intentional living spaces
like why do you care about them I have
it that it fits the form that we like
right I guess
stories that we evolved through the
ecovillage format a multi-generational
you to see people at different stages of
life and really see like a day to day
level harnessing everyone's different
comparative advantages who really makes
things go I'm losing feel much more
integrated and involved
let me have it that humans are just much
happier in that type of format versus
like the nuclear home type of event
family format or even it can it can be
workable in like the Asian
multi-generational like Grandma takes
care of the kid type of thing a lot of
parents and professionals but the
village format it seems like this was
much more cost pollination what are the
default ways of being that you see in
these intentional living communities
that make them so important is like
emotional availability for your neighbor
yeah like the fact that we don't seem to
have that anymore that we don't even
speak with or know their neighbors or
like they do they just know my name
would say hi I'm that's the extent of
the relationship
oh I'm so fragmented what's the guess
what was the value of those what are
other of these states of being in these
communities that you see as valuable to
know thy neighbor one emotional
availability generally there's some
shared mission like being in it together
geographic and conceptual proximity
the faces you make when you're pressing
yonder there's like a little hole that
happens yeah the sense of being in it
together a shared mission yeah being in
it together cool okay what's what's a
shared mission of one that's like an
intentional immunity that you would like
to share well Iko magic is out to create
Fitness between the trajectory our
environment is in and the set of needs
that we have as humans that's like I
mean like that seems like what else what
else is there I mean it's like
satisficing to me the needs of our
humans and the needs of our environment
and what the environment can provide you
hope to very can provide I mean I guess
it's some combination that some of that
space okay cool so shared missions what
else I mean I can yeah yeah what are the
other ones you called them do you think
we're certain um yeah yeah it shapes the
stance I get to take in my life like you
become the average of the five people
you spend the most time around
yeah the frame it expands my range of
abilities of like personality suits to
try on which increases in adaptability
and fitted nasai think oh cool I like
that I like that one a lot
the more different personality suits
that you can put on the more adaptable
we
like do you know how to vibe in a
liberal or conservative neighborhood or
in China or in Russia and Saudi Arabia
or Brazil or in the u.s. yeah and I have
it that you don't really fully
understand something until you can play
that geyser into the spectrum of it yep
yep yep that's a key point to actually I
like that one of the motions in rage huh
same thing with emotions in rage like
there's no true love with that also
experiencing rage about Amy's okay it's
not true love without experiencing rage
it's my provocative Alton statement of
it's not true loyalty unless you have
better options somewhere hmm
as though if there was only the option
of love without any of the other options
that it wouldn't be true love yes so
there has to be the option to add from
love into hate in order for you to know
what true love is
I mean yes so if I'm constantly coached
by super intelligence to go towards love
and that I don't swing into hate that
love will be like mechanized and not
from the heart I mean I don't know it's
possible that you just don't have hate
centers or something in your brain or
something I don't know but like this I
just my experience of the world I mean I
can only generalize from interesting I
mean generally anything that we take
from an external source is going to
result in some mechanized version of the
thing it's always you here the ultimate
decider
I'm really interested to hear other
people's thoughts in the comments on on
this subject and the things that
Ultimates been teaching us yeah I'm
interesting yeah I don't know myself I
serve you and when I know myself I am
you when I don't know myself I serve you
or teach when I know myself I am you
yeah when we know ourselves we are each
other let's talk about super connecting
how do you view nodes people as nodes in
a social network graph with different
spokes as connections between them if
they have just a single line or if they
have a certain amount of weight on that
line maybe the weight is less than on
another line where the connection is
stronger between those nodes how do you
view them unlike a fitness landscape
regarding their spiritual actualization
or their ability to execute ideas how do
you view all of and how do you connect
these people we have this yeah how do
you view all of it how do you yeah okay
how do you engage us a super connector
in the world and see it well I mean if
you're taking my way it's like a certain
texture of the set of people in your
life who are like represented as near
family like there's like a warmth or
like for me my stomach is like more
loose and my shoulders like open and
relaxed my hands and fingers feel like
relaxed and then there's like a certain
texture of people who are like if you
think about a motorcycle gang there's
like a certain like texture my hands
feel like
clammy and my shoulders feel like
shrinking in or if I think of like the
warmest superconductors I know like my
heart I'm much more present to my heart
my chest is more open I notice I speak a
little bit slower my back and my neck
like feel more loose as well
if you think of like the past romantic
partners you've had it's like for me
like let's see it's a whole like my face
feels very like tender and sweet and
soft my fingers feel like reaching out
or like wistful yeah my present to my
heart as well
so there's like a set of textures of
sensations that come to your mind when
you like hold different when I hold
different groups of people and then you
can do the same mental move for specific
people but there's like people like
different textures go well together like
this certain like middle and like wood
textures look nice to get out and see
what it's like the edge of that like
silver thing and that like plastic thing
like pretty okay to go and there's
certain textures there just like that
kind of it and it looks like they garish
or something so I like hold them in mind
is like these different colored textures
and similar people are grouped in
similar spaces in my mind like that and
complementary people like people someone
who's like new to the area is like a
class or like a group and then of that
like fades over time as like a
classifier
but that's very congruent with super
connectors and that like lights up a
whole set of people that want to like
message them whether there's like
there's like a crunchiness of like
hippies they have like I certainly more
earthy felt a sense or tone or something
and they those would like clash with
like the tech bro which has another
texture it's like more like clean
I don't know if that helped generate
something so there's a view of
archetypes of nodal clusters that you're
viewing and then what about example yeah
then what about seeing them on some sort
of a do you mean super connecting like
seeing the these nodal clusters as super
connections between those clusters
because typically I don't even put
everyone on a graph I just have a felt
sense that it's called 2 9 typically
super connecting at least from what I
understand is a lot about seeing that
style of a of a social network graph
based on your ability to connect people
from seemingly disparate fields or even
the same field but that don't know each
other yes that by connecting those two
together create a significant leap
forward in civilizations
advancement yeah thanks yeah
cross-pollination is I see it - yeah
otherwise for me yeah it seems like the
highest compared to vanish thing being
growing up here and feel like have equal
access to basically anything
conversations yeah yeah I just I get the
models of the the people who have
complementary personality types and so
ok so then you do carry some sort of an
social network graph in your worldview
that then you like people who do those
ridiculous math equations they might
it's kind of like some so this is not an
impartial differential equation this is
actually just oh Alton and Alan should
know each other let me make a connection
that type of oh yeah that comment goes
like visit yeah that's what if you're
sure of like this person knows a lot of
people lose like some
but but sometimes the AI coach within
super connecting I think can do a better
job at keeping all of our thousands of
connections and knowing which ones are
like hashtag biotech hashtag VR etc and
then be able to make connections in like
a tinder style game oh yeah I have no
doubt that anybody I'm looking to help
bring that to the world there are so
many projects but that's a really
interesting up with a couple of those
cards to connect Alton with Suzy and
Paul loom with Michelangelo whatever
yeah yeah okay so I mean I don't know if
necessarily is a healthful pattern do
you find super connecting often ends up
in maximizing mind sense oh that's
interesting here's the full circle
this is a container to hold that
interaction and I'd like a crisp clear
follow-ons it's very easy an
intoxicating to get lost in the loop of
shiny object syndrome with new faces but
you just avoiding doing the actual work
that's why it's so attractive to keep
going on to the next event
the next event the next event would be
the one tax person that next event shiny
object syndrome is plaguing our world as
well well and I think maybe you and I
may say this but that's also because a
lot of our neural Nets have been
sensitized to like being receptive to
that and like going to those events or
maybe they're paying us oversaturation
or stimulation in that specific regard
whereas other people are not exposed to
that same amount because they're just
actually just doing the work or they're
actually just haven't been exposed to
those these networks whatsoever yeah
their selection effects yeah sure aware
of the context from which were speaking
yeah yeah I'm gonna check on your energy
levels I feel like I'm a little bit
caretaking but I'm like I mean yeah I'm
probably getting towards yeah I'm
getting towards the rap because it's a
quite late in the evening quite one day
three days I'm not eating something else
okay that's probably how much I'm
playing it with maximizing up in the
numbers on this without having
sensitization towards like how's that
health lever ten and ten right now we
good let's hit some of the classics on
the way out are we all one
now I'm also like oh I know what answer
I get for to have stuff yeah life is one
is so the company created on writing
retreats yes my answer my experience of
the world has been so far yes and within
that experience of the world what have
been your feelings of that one at once
like projects we love emotions girly
intoxicating and curly romanticized and
deceitful and embracing
all the words now whatever my feelings
it's a it's pretty ineffable feels like
it's also undemanding you're like you
know I get some some meditation hours
and then it's just yeah
would you say is the most upstream issue
most root issue that we face listening
noticing how you're listening actively
creates other people what you think are
other people they really just you some
reflection of you
so listening to yourself
of course everything I say I'm saying to
me
I'm creating crisp and safe
psychologically safe containers for
people to practice that skill in their
own lives so they may bring that tellers
I have it he's authentic relating online
platforms very much in service of that
which I'm happy to share as well we put
the link in the bio having to put like
an application I know they're
interesting selection effects around
things like this - okay an application
link in the bio for these online
authentic relating if you haven't seen
yet let's use this let's use this camera
okay it says let's play an authentic
relating game yeah for those that are
listening on audio yeah interesting
listening being the most upstream
what is the purpose of the one
see life is a playground see ball last
play for purpose of it whenever you
describe do it it's like a Rorschach
test
whatever is good whatever
you describe described to it yet seeing
it as a play that's for me huh yeah I
vibe with that collective Symphony a big
canvas that's constantly having art
being made on it expressing a unique
expression every play a unique
expression
how did you uncover that that's the
reality in this moment and so far right
that's reality life is a series
calibration I just felt the most fun to
fit on into my character suit likes it
my ego likes repeating those words so
yeah okay yeah we're in group okay yeah
we're in the group life's a series of
these calibrations and the guests that
come on the program get to calibrate
further audience me other people etc is
humanity a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence sure we're
already there to using a computer file
and I don't know he's got a youtube
series how we already have that through
companies companies are actually super
intelligent since they operate more
effectively than anyone human could and
have some like objective and they will
often you know fall to around like trade
off along trade off on the values as an
individual in service of whatever that
upping the number that you dislike this
I'll imagine you're talking about like
the the super super in television like
the totally a rant thing but slightly
different to me alright
it's basically the same texture to me
last question what do you think is most
beautiful
here we have
this mailing list this
speckling you're smiling like a whole
world
I got a brain body for now
hopefully future me looking back at this
moment
the many Me's I imagine I get to be
through the listening of people here or
yourself and myself
I'm pausing and listening myself I'm
like
Wow
so enriching thank you
thanks for coming on the show
takes off
yes whoo thank you thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on all the things that
almost talking about on the show
we'd love to hear your thoughts on those
things check out the links in the bio
below tollans Facebook page also check
out the link in the bio below two
templates and templates yes right just
beautiful you can find those in the bio
below also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations and your communities and
around the world that you believe in
against sports simulation all of our
links are below
PayPal patreon cryptocurrency you can
design commercial get paid all those
links are in the bio below and go and
build the future manifest your dreams
into the world we love very much thanks
for tuning in and we will see you soon